The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HONG LIU: OK, let us start.
So let me first
remind you what we
did at the end of last lecture.
So we start talking
about how to calculate
the Euclidean
correlation functions
or how to relate the
Euclidean correlation
functions in the boundary field
series to the bulk quantity.
So the question we are always
interested in-- so the question
we are always interested
in in the field theory
is the generating functional.
And so this is defined,
say, in the Euclidean series
to be-- we insert this.
You insert this information
into your Lagrangian.
And then you just calculate
the correlation function
of this exponential, OK?
So even if I write down a single
field phi, single source phi,
and a single operator-- so you
should really understand this
as the collapsing of
all possible operators--
all possible operators and all
possible corresponding sources
you can put in.
And those are a lot
of important things--
is that you should imagine this
exponential as a power series,
OK?
So this expression should-- for
the purpose of the generating
functional.
And this exponential
should be understood
as a power series in phi.
So we expand it in phi.
And then the term
proportion to phi,
then gives you the one-point
function proportion to phi
squared, give you the
two-point function of O.
And the cubic term would
be the three-point function
of O, et cetera.
And so this should--
yeah, this exponential
does not need to make
sense non-perturbatively.
You only need to make sense of
it as a power series of phi,
OK?
You only need to make
sense of it perturbatively
and then just given by the
correlation functions of O.
OK, so this is a
power series of phi,
which is the coefficient
given by the correlation
functions of O, OK?
So this clear?
And then we argued last time
that given the relation phi
x is related to some
operator to some field phi,
to the boundary value of phi.
Yeah, given that,
say, the operator O
is related to some
bulk field phi
and the nominal
[INAUDIBLE] modes,
the boundary value of phi
should be related to the source
corresponding to this o,
then you can in some sense
immediately write down what
this generating function should
correspond to on
the gravity side.
This can be conceivably
just a partition function
with this deformation--
with this deformation.
And then this should be
the same as the partition
function on the gravity side.
Then we should expect
that CFT phi should
be the same as the gravity
partition function reaches
the boundary condition, OK?
So we expect this
to be true, OK?
And so this is just
a heuristic way
of writing the more
precise relation.
For example, for scalar,
the way to understand
this is that phi
xz at z goes to 0
should goes to phi x
z d minus delta OK?
So this is a precise
mathematical meaning
of this relation.
So the boundary
value of capital phi
should be given
by the small phi.
And of course, depending
on different fields,
then this power
may be different.
So last time, we
talked about the, say,
for conserved current, we
just do it to vector fields.
And then this power will be 0.
And then also for the
[INAUDIBLE] perturbation
will be a different
power, et cetera, OK?
So any questions regarding this?
Good.
So now, the thing
is that in general,
we cannot really verify this
relation because the right-hand
side is very hard to compute.
Actually, we don't even know how
to define the right-hand side
in the full quantum
gravitational regime.
And it's just a
formal expression.
Say for quantum gravity
exist, then maybe there should
exist a partition function, OK?
But there is a
regime-- we do know
how to calculate this side.
So this is so-called
classical gravity regime
or also called semi
classical regime.
In the semi classical
regime, which
is the limit which
alpha prime goes to 0
and the G newton goes
to 0 or similarly gs
go to-- string
coupling goes to zero.
And in this limit, one can
formally write this z bulk just
as a Euclidean path integral
of all the bulk fields.
OK, so now I use the convention
for the Euclidean path integral
without the minus sign.
So we just integrate, say--
so this is your action.
Then you integrate over all
possible gravity fields.
Again, this should be
integrated as a collection
of all the fields
on the gravity side,
including whatever scalar field,
gravity, vector field-- you
catch everything, OK?
And there'll be some appropriate
boundary condition-- OK, so
appropriate boundary condition.
And so this SE-- so this SE,
just the Euclidean action--
standard Euclidean action.
Say the Einstein
term and the plus--
say the matter terms, OK.
And then the leading order in
this limit-- and the meeting
order in that
limit, you can just
perform this integral by
saddle point of approximation,
which is say, alpha
prime goes to 0 limit,
kappa goes to 0 limit.
OK, kappa is essentially
the G newton.
So you can calculate
this path integral
by saddle point approximation.
Just solve the equation motion
following from this action, OK?
I assume you all know what's
saddle point approximation.
So the saddle point
approximation you just solve.
So z bulk-- that's given by SE.
Now you evaluate
it at the solution
of the classical
equation motion.
So phi c is just a
classical solution.
It's a classic solution which
satisfies the right boundary
condition.
Correct boundary condition, OK?
So in this limit, we can
really calculate this quantity.
And this is very good news.
This is very good
news because this
limit-- because this limit is
the-- what did we say before?
N equal to infinity.
And the lambda goes to infinity
limit of the boundary theory
of the super Yang-Mills theory.
OK, so we can actually--
so given this,
then essentially we know
the generating functional.
Then we can actually calculate
the correlation functions
in the strongly coupled
field series, OK?
And it's just by solving the
classical gravity equation,
just by solving the
classical gravity equations.
So we conclude-- this is
an important equation.
So let me write it here.
Yes, so let me just make a small
remark-- make a small remark.
So to [? read in ?] order,
this correlation function
essentially is controlled by
this 1 over 2 kappa square.
So this is 1 over 2 newton.
So remember that
previously, we--
when we talk about relation
between the G newton
and the field theory relation,
this is proportional to N
square, N square of
the [INAUDIBLE] theory.
And this is indeed consistent.
So in the saddle point
approximation, the SE,
this is just controlled by 1
over 2 kappa square when we
just [? put it ?] to N square.
And this is indeed consistent
with our expectation
from [INAUDIBLE] theory that the
leading order, the generating
functional, should be
proportional to N square, OK?
We support for normalization.
OK, so now we have obtained
something powerful.
So now we have obtained
something very powerful.
It said in the N
equal to infinity
and the lambda goes to infinity
limit, the logarithm of CFT,
the generating functional,
is related to-- we
said the boundary condition,
the boundary value.
Yeah, this is the
boundary condition.
Yeah, maybe.
Just, we have this,
which is the boundary
value which phi c goes to
z to some power of phi x.
And thus, z goes to 0, OK?
OK?
And this is the part of the
[? non-normalizable ?] mode
for this bulk field phi, OK?
And this a-- so this
precise number a
depends on-- so this
exponent a depends on, say,
dimension of the operator.
Dimension, spin-- say,
possible other quantum numbers
of operator.
So for scalar, we just have this
guy, which we just wrote, OK?
And so let me remind
you for the vector,
for the conserved current,
which is due to a vector field,
to a gauge field, to a
massless vector field--
and then this gives
you a equal to 0.
Yeah, maybe this just gives
you a equal to 0 in this case.
So the leading,
non-normalizable term--
so just the boundary
value of the vector field
is just given by the
source to the current.
And for the metric, we
discussed last time,
is that for the
metric perturbation,
we just do it to
the stress tensor.
So this is corresponding
to a equal to 2, OK?
So where this comes from is
that, remember-- and last time,
we say that A mu-- say if
you have a gauge field,
say a [? mass ?] term, when
you go to the boundary,
then you get a mu then
plus some b mu Z d minus 2.
So you see, there's no power
here, Z equal to 0 here, OK?
Similarly for the metric,
component of the metric,
go to 0, goes to 1
over Z square, say,
the boundary value.
And the boundaries--
yeah, delta g mu
is the source to the-- for
[? T mu. ?] So here, the a is
actually equal to minus 2.
Or a equal to 2, yeah--
a equal to minus 2.
That's right.
OK?
Any questions on this?
Now let me make some remarks.
So the first remark is what
I said a little bit earlier.
It's that the phi x in
this generating functional
should be considered
as infinitesimal.
OK?
So the reason we want
to consider same term
is that what we said before.
We said we should consider
the generating functional
simply just as a power series.
Because we don't want
to take on perturbation
to deform your regional
series, to actually change
your regional series.
We just use it as a
generating function.
So similarly, the same
thing should be considered
the gravity side, OK?
So similarly on the
gravity side-- so this phi
is due to the
non-normalizable mode.
So this non-normalizable mode
should also be infinitesimal.
OK, so don't disturb your
asymptotic ADS geometry.
OK, any questions?
So this is first remark.
The second remark-- now
let me call this equation.
Let me give the equation name.
It said that both sides of star
are actually divergent, OK?
Are actually divergent.
So the left-hand side,
for a very simple reason,
we are considering a
quantum field theory.
We are considering a generating
function of composite operators
in a quantum field theory.
They're always short distance
divergences when the two
operators come together, OK?
So this is just the usual
uv divergences of a QFT.
On the right-hand
side, we will see soon
in the example this
is also divergent.
And the reason it's divergent
is also we have seen it before.
So remember the ADS
metric is like this.
OK, so I write all boundary
directions together
in terms of dx squared.
So because when Z-- when you go
to the boundary, Z goes to 0.
And then the whole
metric blows up.
So essentially, you
have infinite volume.
And yeah, essentially--
so roughly you
can say this is a volume
divergence near boundary
of ADS, OK?
So the relation between
them, of course,
is precisely what we
called IR uv connection.
So the IR-- so the volume
divergences associated, say,
with the space time
have infinite volume
is related to the uv divergences
in the field series sites, OK?
So in order to actually
obtain the finite answer,
we need to renormalize them.
We need to renormalize them.
So the idea to role match
them from the field theory
point of view,
essentially, you need
to add some counterterms to
cancel the divergences, OK?
You need to add the counterterms
to cancel the divergences.
So the similar logic we
do on the gravity side.
So that means that in order to
make sense of this expression,
we introduce a
renormalized action
which is defined by your
original action-- say,
the [INAUDIBLE] action.
But this is divergence.
So we first need
to regularize it.
So we normally do
regularization.
So instead of
evaluating all the way
to z equal to 0, which
will be divergent,
we cut it off at some
z equal to epsilon.
So this is your full space time.
So z equal to 0 is,
again, your boundary.
So you integrate all
the way to z equal to 0.
You will get a divergence.
So we just cut it off at
a z equal to epsilon, OK?
And then we added
the counterterm,
which can be expressed
in terms of the phi
c evaluated at this epsilon, OK?
And this [? displaced ?] row
should cancel the divergence
here, OK?
Should cancel divergence here.
But this St is
much-- so St should
satisfy some simple criterion.
In principle, this
St can be arbitrary,
but should satisfy
some criterion.
First, this must be local
functionals of phi c, OK?
The reason it must be
local functionals of phi c
is because this should come
from short distance physics.
And short distance
physics is not
something we can
really control even
in the renormalizable theories.
Even in the
renormalizable theories,
we just look at
the quantity which
are insensitive to those
short distance physics.
So the short distance physics,
not something we can control.
But one important thing
about short distance physics
is that they all must come
from a single point, OK?
So it means the counterterm
you act must be local, OK?
And of course must be
covariant, et cetera.
So local, covariant-- satisfy
those basic conditions
and the covariant, et cetera,
with all the right symmetry.
Essentially, this is
the only condition
those counterterms
should satisfy.
And then you can just
choose your counterterms
to cancel the divergent
terms here, OK?
But now the key
thing is that this
is different from just throwing
away the divergent term here.
Because this counterterm also
contain some finite terms.
So that's normally, in
the [INAUDIBLE] field
series, that may change
the finite terms here.
And those finite
terms are constrained
by the locality
and the covariant
and [? those ?] symmetries.
And actually, there's no
ambiguity in them, OK?
Even though the divergent
term, in some sense,
there's ambiguity.
But in the finite term,
there's no ambiguity.
And so we will see an example
at the end of this class.
OK, so we need to
renormalize them.
And this is the criterion
to normalize it, OK?
So once we have
renormalized it, then we
can just obtain the
n-point function.
So the general
n-point function--
say, oy x1, on xn-- if you
look at this n-point function,
so let's say
connected, then we'll
be just corresponding
to the standard story.
You just take n derivatives
on the partition function, not
the normalized one.
OK, so you take derivative
over phi 1 corresponding to o1
and then phi 2
corresponding to o2,
et cetera, and the phi
n corresponding to xn.
And then at the end
of the calculation,
after you have done
the derivative,
you set all the phi to 0, OK?
So then you have extracted
n-point function, OK?
So this is the same
that you expand
that exponential in power series
and then only extract terms
power n in phi, OK?
So same thing.
And now because this
is now equal to that--
so we can write this in
terms of gravity quantities.
So writing as n-point
function of SE
will normalize SE as a function
phi c, now phi 1 x1, phi n xn.
Then at the end, you
take phi equal to 0, OK?
All the phi to 0, OK?
So now you in principle, by
calculating the gravity action
with the appropriate
boundary condition,
then you would have obtained
any n-point functions
from the field theory.
Any questions about this?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can we check that
relations start on the lattice?
HONG LIU: Can we check that?
Yeah, in principle, you can.
But it's just not easy to do.
AUDIENCE: Have people tried?
HONG LIU: So people have
tried, not for super Yang-Mills
series.
So there's some version of
these for some matrix quantum
mechanics.
People have tried.
In matrix quantum mechanics
on the left-hand side,
you can actually calculate
using the lattice
or using Monte Carlo.
So maybe not lattice.
It's just a matrix integral.
You can calculate it
using a Monte Carlo
and then can compare
with the gravity.
Then they turned out to agree
with very high accuracy.
But for super Yang-Mills
series, the left-hand side
is not doable yet using
lattice calculation.
So-- and the one
particularly important thing
is the one-point function.
So maybe just separate
it to mention elliptics.
So one-point
function is important
because one-point
function just expectation
value, which of course we
often are interested in.
So if you have a
symmetry breaking,
whether you develop
expectation value
or if you want to extract the
expectation value of a stress
tensor, et cetera.
So the one-point function is
of very special importance
in many cases.
And also, if you know
the one-point function
in the presence of the
source, then essentially,
you actually know the
full n-point function.
Because you can just take
the derivatives here.
Then you can get to the
higher point functions because
of the-- yeah, if you
know the source here,
if you take one
derivative, now you get
two-point function, et cetera.
OK?
So one-point
function-- so one-point
function we can write
as the following.
So you just take one
derivative, delta phi
x, due to this operator, OK?
So now let's do the scalar case.
But similar can be
applied to other case, OK?
So you can just
replace this phi x
by the boundary
value of capital phi.
So this is for the scalar case.
And you could write it
as delta SE of phi c.
On the right I said,
derivative over phi c z, x.
And as z goes to 0.
Because phi c has to
approach phi with this power.
And essentially, you
just replace it, OK?
But the reason we want to write
this form-- because this form
have a very nice
geometric interpretation.
This has a very nice
geometric interpretation
because delta SE, delta
phi c evaluated at z, x
should be equal to phi c z, x.
And this pi, which is
the canonical momentum
conjugate to phi treating
the z direction as time.
This z direction
treating as time.
And so this pi c just means
it's the classical-- means
that this is evaluated to
the classical solution--
classical solution phi c.
So this expression-- is this
expression obvious to you?
AUDIENCE: No.
Just from the other graphs.
HONG LIU: Hm?
AUDIENCE: It's just [INAUDIBLE]
conjugation, essentially,
right?
HONG LIU: Yeah, this is
the-- yeah, actually,
I forgot the name
of this equation.
Maybe it's-- normally
this equation is taught
in the so-called
Hamilton-Jacobi theory.
It's normally called in
the Hamilton-Jacobi theory.
But this is a well-known fact
in the classical mechanics.
Let me just tell you one thing.
So consider you have a, say,
classical mechanical system.
So you move from t0 to t1, OK?
And then suppose
you have already
found your classical solution.
So this is a
classical trajectory.
And then suppose you evaluate
your classical action.
Say so this is t0 to t1 dt,
all evaluated at Xc, Xc dot, et
cetera, OK?
Xc is already
classical solution.
And so this function-- and
let's suppose that Xc at t0
is equal to X0, Xc
at t1 equal to X1.
So this is the initial
value and the final value
of your trajectory, OK?
And then-- so clearly, because
of this boundary condition,
the S depends on X0 and X1.
Then this is an
important statement
in classical mechanics--
is that delta S,
you do the valuation over the
final value of your location.
This gives you the momentum
at that point at P1.
And if you do the
valuation over delta X0,
then that gives you the initial
momentum, the [INAUDIBLE]
or the initial momentum,
at this point, OK?
So if you're not
familiar with this fact,
try to derive it yourself
when you go home.
Take two minutes to derive it.
If you find the right
the way to do it,
it's actually very simple.
Yeah, but it's also in the
chapter 1 of Landau, Lifshitz.
And it's very-- essentially
the first few pages
of Landau, Lifshitz.
You can also take
a look at that.
And now this situation we have
here is very similar to that.
So we are evaluating the
classical action all the way
to some value of z.
And z essentially is the
boundary-- is the time here.
And the phi c is the value
of phi at this value of z,
which is the analog
of our X1 here, OK?
Then you take the derivative--
so this is a function,
a version with that.
Then you take the
derivative over phi c,
which is the value-- because
[? one you ?] take derivative
over X1.
Then here, you get the P1.
There, you get equals 1 in
momentum conjugate to phi, OK?
So this is just the
functional version of that.
Any questions on this?
So now we have a very
elegant expression.
We said the one-point function.
We said now, if you
look at this-- now,
the one-point function-- so even
in the presence of the source,
you just z equal to 0
limit-- z to the power
d minus delta, pi c z, x.
And of course,
this should also be
renormalized because of
here, we renormalized R.
So here, it should
also be renormalized.
And so here-- yeah, OK?
Yeah, so this is
a nice expression.
So it tells you that
the one-point function
you see essentially
just goes one
into a limit of the canonical
momentum to that field
evaluated at the boundary, OK?
So now, with a
little bit of effort,
we will show-- so you
remember phi x, z,
when you go to z equal to 0, as
we said last time equal to Ax,
you have two
asymptotic behavior.
So this A is related
to the source.
So A is related to the phi.
So we discussed last time A
is related to the phi, OK?
So now you can show,
using this expression,
that the one-point
function is actually
exactly equal to 2 nu times B.
And the nu-- yeah, let me
just introduce my notation,
remind you of which we
had been used last time.
You said the delta.
So last time, we
derived this delta
equal to d divided by 2 plus nu.
And the nu is equal
to d squared over 4
plus m squared R squared
for scalar fields, OK?
So you can show--
so we will do that.
We will reach this point at
the end of this class, OK?
So you show that actually, the
one-point function precisely
is given by B.
So this is very nice.
This is very nice.
So you have two
asymptotic behavior.
And one of them is
related to the source.
And the other is related to
the expectation value, OK?
And so I urge you to do a
self-consistency check yourself
as we did last time that the
[INAUDIBLE] you can determine
the dimension of this operator,
which is precisely delta.
And from this
relation, you can also
check that this
relation is compatible.
We said O have
dimension delta, OK?
And delta are given
by that delta.
Again, this you can check just
by the scaling the two side,
the how two sides scale
under the scaling, OK?
AUDIENCE: So usually
in QFT there's
no relation between
the conjugate momentum
and one-point function?
There's no kind of a--
HONG LIU: No, no.
No, this is conjugate
momentum in the gravity side.
This is not--
AUDIENCE: So within
QFT, there isn't any--
HONG LIU: No, this is the
gravity canonical momentum
related to the field
theory one-point function.
This has nothing to do with
canonical momentum on the field
theory side.
So this is the canonical
momentum on the gravity side.
The boundary value of
the canonical momentum
on the gravity side with
the rate of direction
treated as the time, which
gives you the one-point function
in the field theory.
Good.
Good, OK.
So now let's look at
them more explicitly.
So let's now give you
an example to compute
the two-point function
for scalar operator.
And then we'll also
derive this relation.
We'll also derive
this relation, OK?
So before we do that, do
you have any questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I guess
usually in QFT,
when you have Gaussian integrals
and one-point function is
0, in what case does
this happen here?
HONG LIU: Say-- in
many cases, in QFT--
so if you have any state
with a non-zero [? energy, ?]
any state above the
ground state where you
have a non-zero stress tensor.
And then the stress tensor
will have a one-point function.
And so for example, if you
have a symmetry breaking
in the scalar fields, we also
have expectation value, yeah.
And also, if you have
charge density, than
the current will have
expectation value.
Yeah.
Any other questions?
So yeah, actually,
before we do the example,
let me also make a brief
remark why we actually first
considered the Euclidean
correlation functions.
So now first, can
I ask the reason
why we want to do the Euclidean
correlation function first?
Hm?
AUDIENCE: It's easier?
HONG LIU: It's true.
It's true.
And why it's easier?
Hm?
AUDIENCE: You can--
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Usually
Euclidean takes less time.
HONG LIU: It's true.
Yeah, so there's several
reasons maybe to save time.
Actually, we don't
have much time.
Several reasons-- first
Euclidean interval,
you can more easily define
it using the Euclidean path
integral.
And so there's no ordering
issues, et cetera.
And we just have Euclidean
correlation functions.
But the Lorentzian
correlation functions,
there are many of them.
So it depends on the
orderings, et cetera.
And the typical Lorentzian
function cannot be defined
straightforwardly
using path integral.
So except the Feynman
correlation functions,
say time-ordered.
So if you want to look at other
ordered correlation functions,
they cannot be defined
straightforward.
They cannot be defined
straightforward using path
integral.
And so it's much
more complicated.
Actually, for many
applications-- in particular,
say, for the linear response
for the many body system--
say for condensed
matter or for QCD,
et cetera, mostly we're
interested in the retarded
Green function.
And that is not easy to
define using path integral.
And so you need to
develop some other tricks.
So that's why we are
doing the Euclidean first.
OK?
So now let's look at example
two-point function of a scalar,
OK?
So this is essentially
the simplest example.
And for a two-point
function, they only
need to have the
quadratic term in phi, OK?
And that means
here, you only need
to include the quadratic
term in capital phi.
So that means it's enough
just to consider the action
to the quadratic reliable, OK?
So that means that
if we are interested
in the two-point function
to leading order, then
you can just look at
the quadratic action.
And for scalar, then,
for scalar operator O,
then you are just [INAUDIBLE]
massive scalar fields.
So we can write down
Euclidean action.
OK?
You don't have to worry about
the higher order corrections.
And then the metric is the
Euclidean version of this.
It's just the Euclidean metric.
And this is dx
squared-- so dx squared,
Euclidean metric,
dx squared will
be just delta [? mu ?]
mu, dx mu, dx mu.
It's really just the
standard Euclidean metric.
So essentially, we
take the-- so here,
where previously
was minus dt squared
plus the vector x square.
Then we take that dt square
into Euclidean signature.
Then it just becomes
a pure Euclidean.
All right, I hope this is clear.
And then our goal is just
find renormalized phi c using
this action, which satisfies the
right boundary condition, OK?
OK, so this is our goal.
And if we find this guy,
then you take the derivative.
Then you get
two-point functions.
OK, first, let me--
first, you can write down
the canonical momentum with
the z as the time direction.
So this is just-- OK, so
this is canonical momentum.
Under the equation motion--
OK, equation motion.
And again, because of
a translation symmetry
in those X in the
boundary directions,
we can write it in
the Fourier transform.
You can write x, z
in the form of k, z--
so [? expression ?] ikx, just as
we did last time when we solved
the [? free ?] theory.
Then this gives
you-- so you plug
this in when you put in
the explicit metric here.
Then you get z d plus
1 partial z z 1 minus
d partial z phi minus
k squared z squared phi
and then minus m square R
square phi equal to 0, OK?
So this is very similar
to what we did before,
what we did last time when we
talked about normalizable modes
and non-normalizable modes.
This is the same equation.
The only difference is now we
are in the Euclidean signature.
So this equation can
be solved exactly-- so
in terms of Bessel functions.
But actually, we will not need
the explicit solution here
at the end.
So for now, we will not try
to solve it explicitly, OK?
So we only do that at the end.
So now let's first look at
the on-shell action, OK?
So there's a simple trick.
Because this is a quadratic, you
can actually do an integration
by part in the action.
So let's say plug in the-- let's
plug in the classical solution
to this equation, to the classic
equation, into this action.
So let's do an integration
by parts in this term.
Then when you do integration by
parts, then you get two terms.
You get a boundary term come
from integration by parts.
Then you get the bulk term.
So the bulk term can be
written in the following way.
So let me first copy
the m square phi c term.
And then it's the term which
you obtained by integration
by part of that term.
So that term can be
written as partial m
and then plus the boundary term
plus the total derivative term.
Just did a simple manipulation.
I did integration by parts here.
So now you recognize this guy.
It's precisely the combination
which appeared in that equation
motion.
This is always the case when
you have a quadratic action, OK?
So this is just 0.
So we don't need to
worry about this.
So this term just said
[? N ?] equal to 0 on shell.
So this is just equal to 0.
And so we only have
a boundary term.
So this is a total derivative.
But the boundary-- so we
always see the boundary term
in, say, the directions
along the boundary.
So you only need to
worry about the boundary
term in the z direction.
So then this just translated
into the z equal to 0
and the z equal to infinity, OK?
So this is translating to minus
1/2 d dx, then square root g,
gzz.
Only the z direction matters.
Then partial z phi times pi c.
Then z equal to 0
and the infinity.
So now you recognize
this guy is precisely
our pi with some minus
signs-- precisely our pi.
So this can also be
written as 1/2 d dx pi
c and the phi c you write it as
a 0, infinity-- is equal to 0,
is equal to infinity.
So sometimes, we also
write it in momentum space,
which is convenient
because we can solve it
in the momentum space.
So it can also be written as d
dk 2 pi d phi c kz and the pi
c minus k, z, then 0, infinity.
So we have now reduced it to
evaluate this on-shell action
to just two boundary terms at
z equal to infinity and z equal
to 0, OK?
So now, we will later see
that at infinity, with pi
c times phi c at z equal to
infinity just equal to 0, OK.
We will see, OK?
So we will see explicitly that
in the right solution, that
both pi c and the
phi c, they go to 0.
But actually, there's
also a simple way
to argue without looking
at the [INAUDIBLE] solution
that this is actually
generically also
0 for the following reason.
It's that at
infinity, of course,
we want the full solution
to be well-defined.
So we should also require
phi c or partial z
phi c to be finite, OK?
We don't want them to diverge.
Then you have a
singular solution, OK?
So we want them to be finite.
And now you see the pi.
The pi-- you work out
the fact of the pi when
the z goes to infinity is
proportional to 1 minus d
partial z phi, OK?
Because of the square
root g-- square root
g there take the determinant.
It's 1 over z to the
power d, d plus 1.
And the gzz inverse
is the z square.
So you get this power, OK?
You get this power.
So this-- we generically
go to 0 for z
goes to infinity when d
is greater than 1, OK?
So for any dimension
greater than 1,
if we impose this kind
of regularity condition,
then this is always 0.
But in fact, for this case,
if you solve those equations
explicitly, you find actually
even for d equal to 1,
this goes to 0, OK?
So this is actually
generically 0.
So we don't need to
worry about them.
So now let's just focus
on the z equal to 0 side.
Now let's focus on
z equal to 0 side.
OK, so we have this
condition for phi
which we derived last time.
It says phi c should satisfy
some Ax z to the power
d minus delta plus some
Bx, the leading term.
You know, because there
are sub leading terms,
this is a leading term.
And so from that expression,
you can also obtain the pi c
from that expression-- pi c.
And then you can
easily work out.
And that's proportional
to, say, minus A d minus
delta, z to the minus
delta minus delta
B z delta minus d, OK?
So you just take the
derivative, and you find that.
So just intuitively,
you have the same thing,
this z minus d
factor multiplying
the derivative of phi.
So intuitively, now
we go to z equal to 0.
Then this factor
actually is bad.
Because this factor
goes to infinity, OK?
This factor goes to infinity.
So you see that the pi
c indeed is generically
divergent because
of this term, OK?
Generically divergent
because of this term.
So now let's look at
the product between them
because this involves
the product between them.
So the leading term product
between them, phi c pi c,
is proportional to z to the
power of d minus 2 delta, OK?
So this is all the
expression for the delta.
And nu is always greater
than or equal to 0.
So we see that this term
was always divergent.
It's always divergent
for nu greater than 0.
And for nu equal
to 0, it actually
requires a little bit
special treatment.
Because for nu equal to 0, then
delta equal to d divided by 2.
Then these two terms
have the same power, then
become degenerated in
this logarithm term.
And again, it will
be divergence.
But I will not go into that, OK?
So the story is that
this is always divergent.
This is always divergent.
So this will confirm
what we said earlier.
So this tells you that
SE phi c is divergent.
So we need to renormalize it.
We need to renormalize it.
So we need to add the
counterterm to it, OK?
We need to add the
counterterm to it.
So the choice of the
counterterm, as we said before,
should be local
on the covariant.
So here, it's very simple.
We only work out
the quadratic order.
We only need to write down
things quadratic in phi.
So the counterterm should
also be quadratic in phi.
So we can write counterterm
as the following.
So it's easier to write in
the momentum space, say,
evaluated at this epsilon.
So we need to introduce our
cut-off equal to epsilon
and then introduce
a counterterm.
So the counterterm
introduced should be local.
So the local term-- so
at a quadratic level,
all possible local terms
can be written as follows.
We can write it in momentum
space as the following.
Say, as something which
is a function of k
squared-- phi c, k, say,
z phi c minus k, z, OK?
So the criterion is said fk.
So the locality means that fk
must be analytic in k square.
So let me just give
you some intuition.
So this is a compact expression
using momentum space.
But in coordinate space,
it's easy to understand.
So this is analytic
in k squared.
So you expand it in k square.
So k square is this Lorentz
covariant k square--
using this Lorenz
covariant k squared.
Yeah, the same k square is here,
which is a Lorentz covariant k
square.
So you can expand
this in k square.
So the 0-th order
term just a constant.
And the constant, when you go
back to the coordinate space,
this is just phi square, OK?
This is simple.
It's a local term.
You can write in
terms of two phis.
And the next order
term will be k square.
k square, when you go
back to coordinate space,
this will be just partial
phi square and et cetera.
And indeed, these are the only
local terms you can write down.
And so essentially, you can
summarize in the momentum space
just as something which is
analytic in k square, OK?
So now, we want to
choose the k square
to cancel the divergence, OK?
So want to chose the
case-- I chose this
to cancel the divergence, OK?
So now, in order
to do a-- so now I
need to introduce a
little bit of notation.
Because if we want to worry
about the locality-- and it's
not enough just to look
at this leading term, OK?
Look at leading
term-- so remember,
those things-- so those behavior
obtained solving this equation
by setting this to be 0.
So when z goes to 0
limit to leading order,
the kz just goes to 0
compared to this term.
So that expression,
which we did last time,
are obtained by
solving this equation
without this kz squared term.
So we include this
kz squared term
so that we include some
higher order corrections, OK?
We include some higher
order corrections.
But now since we worry about
whether this fk squared
is analytic-- so we have to
worry about those k dependence.
OK, so now let me introduce
some notation, OK?
So let's consider the
basis of solution--
the basis of solutions
to this equation, phi 1,
which I call phi 1, and phi 2.
So phi 1 and phi 2 precisely
are defined by these two
asymptotic behavior.
So phi 1 has the behavior
that goes to d minus delta.
And the phi 2 then
have the behavior
when you go to z equal to 0,
it goes to z to the power delta
as z goes to 0, OK?
So this is the
leading term for phi.
But for small z, this can be
written as a power series.
And then the leading term
will be just like that.
Then you will have,
say, some a1 k
squared z square term come from
treating the next order list
term and also higher order
terms-- say, k4, z4, et cetera.
So similarly, phi 2 z,
k would be start with z
to the power of delta.
Then will be also have
higher order terms.
OK?
So the key is that you can work
out those coefficients, OK?
Because this is local
expansion of infinity,
and you can work out those
coefficients explicitly.
And all the dependents on
k are local in the sense
that they all are
dependant only on k square.
It's because the k square
is what k square appears
in the original equations, OK?
And similarly, you
can work out the pi.
So the corresponding
pi 1 and the pi 2
corresponding canonical momentum
for them equal pi 1, pi 2, OK?
Then the pi 1, pi
2, each of them
will have these
two behaviors, OK?
Each of them will have
these two behaviors
and along with these
higher order terms, OK?
Good?
So now-- so now let's look
at this on-shell action.
So this on-shell action, before
we regularize it, evaluate it
at z equal to epsilon.
So this would be-- oh right,
there's one more step.
Sorry.
So using this
notation, we can just
write our phi c equal to A phi
1 plus Bk same momentum case--
phi 2.
So now these are exact
expression because the phi 1,
phi 2 are two
bases and Ak and AB
are just linear coefficients
of that basis, OK?
And the pi c would
be similarly Ak,
where pi 1 plus Bk pi 2, OK?
So under the SE phi c would
be, if you plug this in,
just have A square pi 1
and phi 1 plus B square pi
2 phi 2 plus AB pi 1 phi
2 plus phi 1 pi 2, OK?
And this is the one
that's divergent.
So this is the one
which is divergent
coming from the
expression we said before.
OK, this is divergent.
And so this is phi
1, this is pi 1, OK?
So this is divergent.
And the other term you can
all check are finite, OK?
So this is divergent.
So we need to cancel this term.
But you cannot just
abstract this term.
You cannot just abstract this
term because this term is not
covariant.
Because A-- because this
term is not covariant.
This term does not have the
form of the phi square et
cetera, does not have
this covariant form, OK?
So this term by itself
is not covariant.
So you cannot just
subtract this term.
But now, you can easily-- so
now, we have phi square here.
So now you can easily pick a phi
just to cancel this term, OK?
Just by comparing
these two, we can just
pick an f to cancel that term.
So it turns out that f can be
written as pi 1 phi 1 times
phi square, OK?
So essentially, this is our f.
It's the ratio between
pi 1 and phi 1.
So now if you expand it,
since I'm out of time-- so
let me not do it here.
If you expand it, you
can easily see this term
cancels that term, OK?
But there are other
terms from the covariant.
So there are also finite
terms brought by this term.
But there's also finite
And this is local because this
is a ratio of pi 1 and phi 1.
And both pi 1 and
phi 1 are obtained
by solving this equation
locally at the infinity
just by power series and
dependence on k squared.
It's always analytic, OK?
So this is guaranteed.
So this is analytic
function of k squared.
OK, so you take a
little bit of exercise.
You work out what is a
here, a1 here, et cetera.
Then you can write this
term more explicitly
in terms of standard term
like phi square, partial phi
square, et cetera, OK?
So now you add
these two together.
You get a renormalized
counterterm, OK?
Then you find the
renormalized expression.
renormalized expression
is SR phi c is
given by 1/2, again
in momentum space,
2 nu A, minus k, Bk.
So you find everything
depends on phi 1, pi.
They all disappear in the end.
You just get
something like this.
You get a finite term like this.
So now this is ambiguous.
It's all finite and ambiguous.
So this is your on-shell action.
So normally, what we do is
that we solve this equation.
Then we can find the
explicit A and B.
So we solve this equation
with the following boundary
conditions.
It said we first impose
the boundary condition.
You have Ak equal to phi
k because A is the source.
A is identified with the source.
But we also need to
impose regularity
at z equal to infinity.
So we wanted the solution
to be well-defined
at z equal to infinity.
So it turns out these are the
two conditions which uniquely
determine the solution.
So that means these
two conditions together
which will determine
B in terms of A. OK,
so this will determine
B in terms of A.
So in particular, this
is a linear solution.
So B will have the form which--
some number chi times A. So chi
is the thing which you
determine by solving
the equation explicitly, OK?
This is a form-- chi you obtain
from solving the equation.
Just short a couple minutes.
It's just-- so now you
plug this into that.
You plug this into that.
Plug this into that.
Unfortunately, I
erased my equation.
OK, so you plug this into that.
So chi you assume is
some known function
which you obtain
after you are solving
the equation explicitly.
Then what you get--
so without that page.
So what you get is you will
get S renormalized action phi
c equal to 1/2 the integration.
So 2 nu Ak-- 2 nu
lambda-- or we here
call chi-- Ak and
A, minus k, OK?
So you remember this
is just all phi k.
This is just all phi k.
So now you can obtain
the one-point function.
Just take the derivative
over phi-- say, minus k.
You get the Ok.
And this is precisely
just 2 nu chi times Ak.
And this is
precisely 2 nu B, OK?
And you can write it
in the coordinate space
also, Ox equal to 2 nu B.
So this we derive
in the linear order
by looking at the
quadratic equation motions.
But actually, this turns out
you can prove it actually
to all order.
You work with nonlinear
equations, et cetera,
you can show this is always true
that the one-point function is
always given by this B, OK?
One-point function is
always given by this B.
So let me say one thing.
So now the two-point function--
so the two-point function, you
just take two derivatives.
You take two derivatives.
So that just gives
you 2 nu chi, OK?
Just the 2 nu chi.
So this can also be
written as 2 nu B divided
by A because the
chi is equal to--
and this makes perfect
sense physically
because this is our Euclidean
correlation function, OK?
And the 2 nu divided
by A can also
be written using
what we write there.
So this is the
expectation value divided
by phi k divided by the
source, so A because it's phi
and 2 nu B is expectation value.
And then we see this
expression is precisely
a so-called linear response.
The expectation value in
the presence of the source
is the correlation
function times the source--
the correlation
times the source.
So again, this equation
is completely general.
So for any two-point
function case,
we'll always find this B
divided by A times 2 nu.
And you can also
alternatively written it
as the ratio O
divided by phi, OK?
So just the final minute.
Now you can solve the
equation explicitly.
So now you can solve
the equation explicitly.
You can solve the
equation explicitly.
And you can solve your [? eom ?]
using the Bessel function.
And then you find that
actually, the function which
is no [INAUDIBLE] the infinity
at z equal to infinity
is given by this form.
k-- so this Bessel k
function with index nu.
Nu is the same as this nu.
And then from here, you
just expand in small z.
Then you can find
the B divided by A.
Then you find B divided by A
as gamma, minus nu, gamma nu.
So from here, you just
expand in small z.
And then you extract
different power.
You obtain the ratio
of B divided by A, OK?
So as you get gamma
nu-- minus nu,
gamma nu k divided by
2 to the power 2 nu.
So you find the
two-point function.
So since the two-point
function is just the 2 nu B,
A-- so you find the
Euclidean two-point function
in momentum space.
It's just 2 nu gamma,
minus nu, gamma nu,
k divided by 2 to the 2 nu.
So in some sense,
this is precisely what
you expect because
we are working
with the conformal field theory.
And the two-point function can
only depend on k as a power
because there's no other scale.
There's no other scale.
And the power is determined by
the dimension of the operator.
And for example, if you go
to the coordinate space--
so you Fourier transform,
go to coordinate space.
So that just gives you the
X to the power 2 delta.
Sorry-- I will stop here.